millionen deutsche haben nicht schlecht
gestaunt am wochenende zdf fernsehgarten
der gute laune sonntag mit der immer gut
gelaunten andrea kiewel doch die muss
offenbar guten dinge machen zum gender
wahnsinn die promi moderatorin in ihrer
sendung vom zdf offenbar zum ländern
gezwungen
der deutschen singer songwriter innen
szene ja und genau diese nicht nicht das
gesicht verziehen ich muss und genau in
diese kategorie ja nicht das gesicht
verziehen ich muss sagen
da von andrea kiewel das sorgt jetzt für
heftige diskussionen
eine promi moderatorin also die gendern
muss fragen wir uns obwohl sie das
selbst möglicherweise für gaga hält der
deutschen singer songwriter innen szene
ja und genau diese nicht nicht das
gesicht verziehen ich muss und genau in
diese kategorie wie bitte ich muss
andrea kiewel am sonntag im
fernsehgarten deutet die moderatorin
hier etwa einen gender zwang im
öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk an die
empörung jedenfalls ist groß und andrea
kiewel oder zugleich zurück gegenüber
bild stellt die moderatorin klar niemand
nicht das zdf und sonst auch niemand
sagt mir dass sich ändern muss ich
benutze den männlichen und weiblichen
purer schon seit langer zeit weil ich es
unbedingt will und es mir sehr wichtig
ist es liegt mir am herzen
auch das zdf selbst äußert sich stellt
klar es gibt keine anweisungen zum
ländern im zdf fernsehgarten absurde
gender formen im gebührenfinanzierten
fernsehen und wirklich kein einzelfall
der gender waren erscheint hier methode
zu haben ausbildung hat sie ehrenamtlich
neben ihrem eigentlichen job gemacht und
der ist nun wirklich ausführen intensiv
krankenschwester in bitte was
krankenschwester in ja tatsächlich
sie haben richtig gehört lokalzeit
moderator stefan fuchs spricht
tatsächlich von krankenschwester in
gender gaga in reinform aber es geht nur
absurd ab ende juli im bayerischen
rundfunk in der sendung diversity talk
2022 sollen schon die jugendlichen
publikum fit gemacht werden für das zu
ändern doch die haben ihren eigenen kopf
rotieren im anschluss eine diskussion
mehrheitlich gegen das zu ändern ganz
zum unmut von moderatorin stammen die
das publikum im nächsten jahr am
liebsten zum nachsitzen schicken würde
also es hat niemand überzeugt die runde
jetzt
also ich glaube es ist tatsächlich einen
aufruf sozusagen nächstes jahr wieder
diese veranstaltung zu machen der gender
waren im öffentlich rechtlichen rundfunk
scheint ihr eine heimat gefunden zu
haben der deutschen singer songwriter
innen szene ja ob auf zwang oder ganz
freiwillig die gebührenzahler und solche
die es bald schon werden haben
jedenfalls genug anrufe für kiebel
umfrage klatsche für stand die zuschauer
sprechen eine klare sprache ganz im
gegensatz zu denen die sie bezahlen
müssen
[Musik]